[Música]
estación central de kiev 7 de la mañana
vitaly regresa a su casa cinco semanas
después de la huida del ejército ruso
su ciudad es ahora un símbolo de las
destrucciones ocasionadas por moscú
[Música]
quiero volver a irte
pero me da miedo descubrir que mis
amigos seres queridos o mis vecinos
fueron torturados y asesinados por los
rusos
mientras tanto vaya a ver si dado
ahora el pin es una ciudad fantasma
cuando vital y buyó las explosiones se
escuchaban en todo el barrio
los hábitos
un día estaba aquí fumando un cigarrillo
con un amigo
escuchamos el silbido de un obús lanzado
por un mortero las explosiones
hubo tres explosiones grandes habrían
podido destruir todo fue una noche
terrible
los rusos dejaron trampas en varias
casas antes de su retirada pero según
los vecinos de vitaly no entraron a su
apartamento
ven barbaris acá entremos a la casa
departamento realmente es un caos
para evitar que los vidrios estallara y
se cayeran al suelo subimos las ventanas
[Música]
trueba
tengo que limpiar todo
y
me siento tan feliz de tener un lugar al
que volver
[Música]
antes de la guerra 70.000 personas
vivían en irvine
la mayoría ha oído a diferencia de vital
y muchos se han quedado sin un lugar al
que puedan volver
gran parte de las viviendas quedó
destruida
volví el 15 de abril
cuando entré a mi apartamento vi que
todo estaba tirado en el suelo
los rusos tumbaron las puertas y
entraron a saquear
estaban celosos de nuestras vidas y
todavía lo están
[Música]
decían que habían venido para una
operación especial
yo creo que esa operación especial solo
consistía en destruir nuestro modo de
vida
en su residencia los misiles rusos
destruyeron prácticamente todo los
apartamentos que no estallaron se
quemaron estos voluntarios vienen a
buscar todo lo que aún pueda rescatarse
las personas que vivían aquí tendrán que
mudarse a un garaje estamos recuperando
sus muebles después el edificio se
demolerá para construir otro
la alcaldía estima que el 70 por ciento
de la ciudad quedó afectada por los
combates se necesitarán más de 830
millones de dólares para reconstruir la
polo de mir limpia la habitación de su
hijo con la esperanza de que regrese
pronto
no lo he visto desde hace un mes creo
que está bien está creciendo poco a poco
hablo con él todos los días
y su familia huyó el primer día de los
combates las balas atravesaron su
apartamento
también la ventana
pero pienso que los rusos podrían volver
algún día
entonces decidí cubrirlas con un
plástico en caso de que vuelvan a
romperse broken mientras la guerra sigue
afectando severamente al país la
reconstrucción en mipim comienza las
autoridades invitaron a 120 arquitectos
deben elaborar una estrategia para
reconstruir la ciudad
para decidir si las personas todavía
pueden vivir aquí debemos estudiar todo
el edificio
así podremos saber si existe un riesgo
de que se derrumbe
si el resultado es bueno haremos todo lo
posible por reforzar la estructura
cualquier naturiva interpretaba
se necesitará bastante tiempo para que
irving renazca de sus cenizas más de 100
edificios residenciales quedaron
destruidos muchos habitantes temen que
en caso de una nueva ofensiva haya
también nuevas destrucciones
[Música]